[Music]
what do you do when the game you love is
literally destroying your body the whole
time I was hopeful that I would
eventually get my wrist issues resolved
to a good enough degree that I'd be able
to play again what do you do when you're
one of the best players in the world
only to be taken down by an injury
caused by playing the game I'm terrified
to see how good this kid's gonna be in
like two years most people would just
quit give up and try something else but
not hats hats refused to give up and he
took matters into his own mangled hand
and came up with his own way to play oh
nice spacing
oh that's big thing Oh Mike oh that's
big damage that is big damage and hacks
wins three one three one and I'm
thinking to myself back up stage pass
getting the light neutral eSport stars
have been dealing with injuries for
years so you've obviously feel that you
aren't playing very well boy I have
reasons I had the hand injury and it's
hard to come back for me siento momento
butcher thank you hope we didn't see it
hard on you - oh yeah great party -
kinda crazy like yeah no matter what
game every scene has had at least one
Pro had to bow out prematurely because
of an injury sustained while playing
their game but while there are dozens of
ergonomic solutions for PC game players
melee players have a unique problem
smash players spend all day tightly
gripping their controllers combine that
with quick repetitive movements and
minor discomfort couldn't quickly
snowball and turn into serious injuries
and chronic pain people are sitting here
for like eight hours a day and they're
moving their thumb back and forth so
quickly it looks like a chainsaw and it
really is a catalyst for like all sorts
of problems it's a struggle that aziz
hacks al Yami knew all too well in 2013
hacks was the sixth best melee player in
the world right behind the five gods
here's the here's the cuss of combo
there's a custom combo Oh
haxe was known as the best captain
falcon player in the world he was a
master of risky plays and flashy combos
but he felt like something wasn't
missing sure
cabin falcon had taken him this far but
he felt like he couldn't go any further
without switching characters so it was
time for a change
winning with captain falcon for me I
think out of the question so I switched
to Fox in 2014 so I really wanted to
challenge myself um and you know Fox fit
the bill like he's super fast high APM
fun to play and I also think um the
community perceives a lot of a lot of
his stuff as like not humanly realistic
to consistently execute and I strongly
disagreed with that I strongly disagreed
with the idea that you couldn't just
practice the hell out of fox and nail to
start nailing these things like 90
percent of the time I like that but just
jumped fully over everything and then we
made a neared late to get but it didn't
work out at HUBO MLG 2014 hacks felt
what he described as an explosion in his
left wrist and that was only the
beginning of his troubles at this point
the amount of everyday pain I was in was
insane I had four things going on and I
couldn't find a surgeon to operate who
would operate and perform that first
thing I needed done which is to have my
FCU removed the pain got so bad that in
January 2015
haxe was forced to take an indefinite
hiatus from smash a lot of people were
thinking that I actually had a chance of
winning a TX 2015 but then I ended up
not entering because of really bad hand
problems um that was when things like
started to come crashing down in 2015
basically hacks his doctor has
discovered problem after problem with
his hands and not one of them was
willing to take the risk associated
with fixing those problems there are
basically two sides to my my my injuries
the wrist injuries there on the ulnar
side of my wrist which is the side of
the pinky finger and that was where I
had like a big one-time injury I was
showing signs of basal thumb joint
arthritis and all the way back then in
2014 the doctor told me like don't even
worry about this it hasn't really
progressed yet but in hindsight that was
actually a ridiculous thing for the
first doctor that I ever went to to tell
me because no one should be showing
signs of basil come join our thright us
at you know such an early age
to keep himself sane haxe started
playing League of Legends he even made
it to Challenger becoming one of the top
200 players in North America but League
wasn't the game that haxe wanted to play
he was still dreaming of coming back to
competitive melee but the doctor has had
more bad news for hacks and then the
doctor who did the fort surgery on me to
fix my wrist had said you need to quit
because your thumb arthritis is
progressing he said like you have to
stop using that controller that you play
on I showed him the motions and he
explained why
ergonomically that was like the worst
thing for the basal thumb joint he had
ever seen my whole world kind of came
crashing down because I was like okay so
I basically just sat here playing League
of Legends for the past two years
because I was thinking I'm eventually
gonna get my wrist fixed and come back
if you've never had an injury that held
you back from doing what you love it's
hard to explain just how much it can
break you as a person according to the
doctors hacks had no way of returning to
the game he loved and made him feel
hopeless my number-one goal like in life
is to return to melee and be the best
like that's just all I want to do I
think about it every single day and so
for him to tell me that your career is
over I felt empty completely if hacks
couldn't use a gamecube controller well
he had to just find another way to play
melee without defying his doctor's
orders there's no true fix for arthritis
and so that was devastating you know
because that then that made me realize
like I still
can't play even after he fixes my wrist
I still can't play all this waiting was
for nothing
and that was when I realize I needed a
new controller entirely and a chance
encounter half a year earlier God him
thinking about how he could make that
happen
and it hit me that half a year back I
had seen the smash box in person at evo
2016 at the time I didn't really think
much of that product like at Evo I
didn't think too much of it I thought
like oh it's a cool novelty but I don't
think III could never actually use this
to play to play me like at a
professional level with and I don't
really think anyone else could either
but I went out on a limb and I contacted
Dustin because I was gonna I was
grasping at straws I was gonna take any
chance that I could and haxe realized
that he wasn't going to be the last
casualty of the horrible on ergonomic
GameCube controller it really worried me
that that could be something that it's
gonna be an issue in the industry going
forward potentially because I'm not the
only one who's like abusing my thumb as
hard as I did when I was just you know
playing Falcon like more people could
have this and they might be unaware of
it
hacks teamed up with Dustin Huffer and
the rest of the hit box team as a play
tester for their new controller the
smash box and this is where things get
really murky the smash box team alleges
that hacks tried to push his ideas about
what the controller should look like and
eventually he left the project but stole
their design ideas to just do his own
controller what this all comes down to
because of this is a battle of
credibility who are you gonna believe
the 22 year old kid hacks money who blew
up his own wrists ignored every single
doctor that tried to help him and is now
after he's got his second lease on life
as he likes to say is still actively
[ __ ] on everybody who's trying to
help him I've known Hass for five years
he's not a business associates me he is
someone who I knew personally and he
betrayed me for his own self-interest
hacks and the Smashbox team still don't
agree on what happened behind the scenes
but the community ended up rallying
behind hacks people need me benefit of
the doubt at first which I really
appreciate
like when the when the war between us
like first broke out on people gave me
benefit of the doubt because they knew
me as like one of the top professionals
whereas Smashbox didn't have anyone like
that working for them
unfortunately tournament organizers
weren't as enthusiastic many tos decided
to ban non-traditional controllers like
the box because they felt it gave people
using them an unfair advantage over
players using the traditional GameCube
controller but hax was determined to
prove that the Box should be legal for
tournament play after all if his only
way to play smash was banned then he was
back to square one hacks went as far as
writing up a 150 page document arguing
his case and that did the trick the box
has a lot of self-imposed limitations
whereas the smash box was marketed as
like the perfect controller because with
the smash box you can do a lot of
techniques in this game that are
completely unrealistic on a GameCube
controller and with his tailor-made
controller in hand pax was back that's
gonna hurt right now down three stocks
to one down set
one event light for us not really what
we expected from you know a player we
just had
little bit of a breakout turns out last
week and got sue with that big onset of
the same right now he's potentially
about to be eliminated by hacks just
like that wow that was a fast set like
he you have to almost respect you have
to stay like a good enough distance away
cuz he's gonna have a less shock action
on out of Sheol it's like on the floor
to like you know go he's playing on fire
right now Brad oh it's definitely a
comeback like right now I'm actually
skill wise I'm I'm at my best ever
some members of the community still
wonder if hack switching to Fox is what
exacerbated his hand issues in the first
place since Fox takes so much technical
precise movement but Pat stands behind
his main on this one it's actually a
really big misconception I had the AI
hand had the hand issues on like the
long-term ones like the arthritis they
were they were already developing like
back since the Falcon days today more
than ever
hacks is trying to prove himself and
he's done with using his injuries as a
crutch that's why I had to come back
because I knew like I could actually be
the best at this game and now I'm
basically like top ten again I'm
basically like number 10 or 11 in the
world hacks is living proof that second
chances do exist and he wants to use his
to improve the scene he spent so long
trying to get back into most people
would just quit they would give up and
do something else [ __ ] my faucets
dripping and I'm looking at it's not
dripping but I hear the like oh wow that
was a terrible moment for me that you
are a hundred percent Andrew okay well
hopefully the mic is I'm picking it up I
have no idea